good to see you both
congratulations on season six guys what
an accomplishment to get here
i know i feel like we've been doing this
the whole lives now season six here we
go
yeah
about for covered did not help
yeah but it pulls together so
beautifully and the emotional impact
of what happens in season five carries
through i'm curious about how that
affects um both of you guys both of your
characters really and how they approach
life now after all that's happened
well i think in the preceding seasons
we've had roger and brianna go through
traumas that they've very much tried to
be there for each other through but
really have ended up
failing for whatever reason to none foot
no fall of their own but then
because of that consequentially gone
through their trauma and their
healing of it alone or attempt to heal
of it whereas this season it's the first
time that we really see them as a strong
unit i think now that they have realized
that the 1700s is the home and they
they're going to be where they're going
to be for a while they've just become
these really settled
calm version of themselves and
same settled calm version of a team um
and they've just really got each other's
backs and they're just a real rock to
each other and so it's a really strong
season for us in terms of their
relationship because it's just a dynamic
that we haven't really seen in them
before and it's beautiful
something i love about this cast is you
guys are all so multi-talented it's like
you can all do everything richard you're
a great photographer you posted some
beautiful photos of your cast mates on
instagram i'm wondering
who is always the most photoshoot ready
for you like who's got blue steel in
their back pocket ready to go
i mean it's going to be sophie it's got
to be softly but i think
that i think
by default because
most of the time i'm with sophie
she enjoys you know she enjoys doing a
little photo shoot here and there and i
enjoy doing it so we often obviously
we're in costume we have a great
backdrop we have a great set and the
scenery is great why not it's a great
place to shoot and a lot of them are
really really most of them are really
excellent
you know it's not all being kind
because he also knows because we spend
that much time together he knows all my
bad angles so if i'm not nice to him
he's got some real stinkers in there
the cast are really gracious with it
though because
the kids just as easily tell me to you
know
bugger off but they are actually very
gracious and let me do photos and
portraits and they'll hang about and let
me do extra shots here and there and
uh
it's it's actually just a wonderful
experience to do and and for them to
feel that they want to be involved in it
so it's it's just an extra little bit to
our day you know
that's awesome well one of the things
that fans appreciate you know is that
you guys share your friendship with them
you know they get to see it off screen
as well as on screen so that's my time
but i just want to say thanks so much
for the time you guys congrats on season
six thanks
you